Коли ми виїжджали, я думала, що як ми поїдемо до Німеччини,
з якою воювали стільки років?
Чотири роки із Гітлером у фашистській Німеччині воювали.
Свій 102 день народження Тамара Василівна
зустрічала вже у безпечній Німеччині.
Нині, трохи прийшовши до тями від стресу,
жінка з болем і страхом пригадує день,
коли під свист ракет їй довелося тікати з Харкова.
Разом із сімдести-річною донькою та онукою.
Було страшно 5 березня виїжджати.
Коли ми сідали в потяг, то він був повністю набитий людьми,
неможливо було навіть пройти в туалет.
Треба було на когось наступити або через когось переступити
і ми фактично повзком переміщалися.
Потім ми прибули до Львова, а вже потім на пропускний пункт до Польщі.
І далі вже тільки дивом через Краків
ми потрапили сюди - до Німеччини.
Лишати Харків Тамара Василівна не хотіла.
Каже: "Діти наполягли".
Без кінця бомбардування, бомбування, бомбардування, стрілянина…
То там будинок розбомбили, то там будинок розбомбили.
Нам стало дуже страшно, і ми мусили їхати,
схопили все, що було.
Німці, Гітлер зі своєю фашистською армією так Харків не розбомбив,
як це зробили російські війська.
Коли ми увійшли до Харкова, звільняти його,
він, звичайно, був зруйнований.
Але основні будівлі були цілі.
А зараз часто б'ють ракетами невідомо куди.
Путін, мені здається, навіть сам не розуміє, що він робить.
Я його зараз порівнюю з Гітлером.
І вважаю - це другий Гітлер у нас.
Тамара Василівна дійсно добре пам'ятає деокупацію
Харкова після Другої світової війни.
Жінці було лише 20 років коли почалася війна і вона,
вчителька фізики та математики,
вирішила йти на фронт медсестрою, допомагати пораненим.
Під Фатежем у мене було перше бойове хрещення
із серйозно пораненими військовими.
У когось були вирвані сідниці. У когось рука зламана.
А я боялася підійти до цих поранених.
Як перев'язати цю рану?
Тремтячими руками я робила їм перев'язки
зі сльозами на очах.
А на мене солдат накричав і каже: "Що ти за медсестра?"
Мене солдати самі навчили всьому.
Побачили, що я реву над цією раною.
І почали мене вчити, як накладати якісь пов'язки.
Тоді, рятувавши російських солдатів під час війни,
жінка і подумати не могла,
що в майбутньому їй доведеться від них же і тікати.
Це несподівано! Ми не очікували.
Взагалі незрозуміла мені досі ця війна
і скільки вона триватиме.
Такої агресії ми ніколи не очікували з російської сторони.
Росія - рідна країна, це наші брати.
Багато хто працює в Бєлгороді та в Росії,
багато хто працює і виїжджає з Донецька туди.
Я не можу в це повірити, бо до Путіна ми дуже добре ставилися.
Я вважала, що Путін - це такий міністр, президент, солідний.
А після того, як він напав на Харків,
знову я його інакше, як Гітлера, більше не сприймаю.
Він так само чинить, як Гітлер з нами вчинив у 41 році,
так зараз чинить Путін з нами.
Нині з родиною бабуся знайшла прихисток у німецькому місті Мюльгайм-на-Рурі.
Тут вона в оточенні дітей та онуків відчуває себе безпечно.
Перебуваючи тут ми переконалися в тому,
що народ прекрасний у Німеччині.
Коли я йду гуляти цією вулицею, то школярі та дорослі
мене зупиняють, співчувають нам, що ми приїхали сюди.
Завжди вітаються, запитують:
"Як здоров'я? Як самопочуття?" І діти вітаються завжди.
Молодь прекрасна.
І люди у Німеччині дуже добрі.
102-річною бабусею тут опікується онука та її чоловік Сергій.
Сергій - власник місцевого ресторану,
на другому поверсі якого і живе вся родина.
Сам він із Харкова у Німеччину переїхав 20 років тому.
Та з початком повномасштабної війни каже,
що все життя стало на паузу.
В ресторані доводилося розміщати українських біженців,
збирати гуманітарну допомогу, відправляти фури.
Збирали речі, медичні засоби, збирали їжу
та відправляли до України, приймали біженців.
Минулого року відвозили генератор у дитячий будинок
"Зелений гай" у селищі Високе під Харковом.
Ми відвозили у різні райони та лікарні,
5-ий пологовий міста Харкова,
військовий госпіталь Києва, під Києвом, Ірпінь.
Деякі з біженців навіть залишилися працювати у ресторані.
Я прийшла сюди мити посуд,
потім я допомагала на кухні,
в холодному цеху ми робили закуски та десерти.
Зараз працюю або як барменка,
або як офіціантка на різних заходах.
Тут, в основному, працюють українці.
І всі ставляться до цього з розумінням.
Але ми дуже сумуємо за батьківщиною,
лишатися не плануємо. Хочемо на Батьківщину - в Україну.
Вдома краще. Тут дуже добре, великий досвід.
Єдина проблема - це мова.
Ми не ходимо на курси, не встигаємо, більше працюємо.
А мовний бар'єр заважає.
Тому ми інколи не розуміємо, що нам кухарі говорять.
Але вже вони нас розуміють, ми їх навчили української мови.
До допомоги ЗCУ Сергій долучає і бабусю.
Так всі разом у ресторані ліпили вареники на продаж,
а на виручені кошти купили авто для харківської бригади.
Ми змогли таким чином зібрати гроші
і купити авто для ЗСУ - Opel Vivaro на 10 чоловік.
І бабуся ліпила ці вареники разом з іншими українками
та українцями, які або переїхали, або тут жили.
За одне життя Тамара Василівна вже пережила 2 війни.
Попри біль і втрати вона намагається насолоджуватися
часом разом із дітьми та онуками.
І вже має чіткі плани на майбутнє -
повернутися жити до Харкова після війни.